>> Announcer: AMERICANS HELD
HOSTAGE BEHIND ENEMY LINES,
DAY 6.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
THIS FRIDAY NIGHT, AMERICANS
HELD HOSTAGE BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
THIS IS A 6, AND THERE IS SADLY,
WE CAN REPORT, NO END IN
SIGHT TONIGHT.
A MONTH AGO IN JULY, SECRETARY
OF STATE ANTONY BLINKEN, HE WAS
WARNED IT DIRECTLY FIVE WEEKS
AGO, BY 23 TOP DIPLOMATS INSIDE
OF AFGHANISTAN, THAT THE FALL OF
KABUL WAS, IN FACT, IMMANENCE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IGNORED
THAT DIRE WARNING, AND HERE WE
ARE, IN THIS SITUATION, AT THIS
HOUR, WHERE THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
OUR AFGHAN ALLIES, ARE IN
EXTREME DANGER.
THEIR LIVES ARE AT RISK.
MANY OF THESE ALLIES WILL BE
MURDERED IF THEY ARE LEFT
BEHIND, AND THE WORST PART OF
ALL IS EVERY BIT OF THIS WAS
PREVENTABLE.
BUT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HE HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY CHECKED OUT, MISSING
IN ACTION, HE ENDURED EVERY
CLEAR WARNING THAT THIS WAS ALL
GOING TO OCCUR, IN A PRESS
CONFERENCE EARLIER TODAY,
JOE BIDEN ONCE AGAIN
SHOWED HIS TRUE COLORS,
REPEATEDLY TOLD OUTRIGHT LIES TO
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
A MAN WITHOUT CHARACTER, CAREER
POLITICIAN, CLEARLY NO MORAL
COMPASS, WITHERING, DECREPIT
SHELL OF A HUMAN BEING, WHO PUTS
HIS OWN PRIORITIES, OBVIOUSLY,
ABOVE THOSE FELLOW AMERICANS
ABROAD.
AND UNTIL MIDDAY TODAY, JOE'S
PLANS WERE TO GO BACK ON
VACATION IN DELAWARE UNTIL HE
WAS PRETTY MUCH ASHAMED INTO
STAYING AT THE WHITE HOUSE FOR
THE WEEKEND.
THE REALITY FOR THE COUNTRY IS
THIS: WE REALLY DON'T HAVE A
PRESIDENT, SEEMINGLY AWARE AND
CAPABLE OF LEADING.
JUST WATCH JOE BIDEN LIE AGAIN
AND AGAIN TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK THE
LOGISTICS OF EVACUATION, WE ARE
IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH THE
TALIBAN, WORKING TO ENSURE
CIVILIANS HAVE SAFE PASSAGE TO
THE AIRPORT.
>> Sean: SAFE PASSAGE TO THE
AIRPORT.
PLEASE TELL ME HE IS NOT
SERIOUS, BECAUSE HIS OWN STATE
DEPARTMENT SENT A MEMO TO THOSE
TRAPPED IN AFGHANISTAN AGAIN
TODAY, REITERATING "THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT CANNOT INSURE YOUR
SAFE PASSAGE TO THE AIRPORT."
OH, AND THE GATES MIGHT CHANGE
FROM TIME TO TIME HERE AND MAYBE
JOE DID NOT GREET HIS OWN
STATE DEPARTMENT MEMO.
AND LOOK AT THIS, IN A BRIEFING
CALLED "WITH LAWMAKERS," LLOYD
AUSTIN SAID AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
BEATEN BY THE TALIBAN IN KABUL,
OUTSIDE OF THE AIRPORT.
SOME WERE BEATEN WITH RUBBER FAN
BELTS.
JOE BIDEN CLEARLY LIED, HIS OWN
STATE DEPARTMENT AND HIS OWN
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT ARE
HIGHLIGHTING THESE LIES.
THE TALIBAN IS ABSOLUTELY NOT
ALLOWING SAFE PASSAGE.
WATCH WITH YOUR OWN EYES.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE HAS NO
INTELLIGENCE THAT AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO GET THERE.
THE QUESTION, OBVIOUSLY, DOES
THAT SQUARE WITH REPORTING ON
THE GROUND?
>> I MEAN, NOT.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWING ANYONE TO
GO INSIDE.
>> GETTING INTO THE AIRPORT
ITSELF, IT WAS JUST
HEARTBREAKING, PEOPLE PUSHING,
SCRAMBLING, CRYING, SCREAMING,
CHILDREN CRYING OUT.
[CHILD CRYING]
[INTERESTING SHOUTING]
>> Sean: IF YOU CAN'T GET IN,
YOU ARE OBVIOUSLY THEN A HOSTAGE
BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE, "CNN,
ABC, NBC, FOX NEWS
CORRESPONDENCE, FACT-CHECK BIDEN
ON AFGHANISTAN EVACUATIONS.
THE REALITY AND THE RHETORIC ARE
MILES APART."
OUR VERY OWN JENNIFER GRIFFIN
SAID "I AM HAVING A HARD TIME
DIGESTING WHAT WE HEARD BECAUSE
I COULD IN FACT-CHECK IT IN --
FAST ENOUGH IN REAL TIME."
WHAT IS THE POINT OF CONTROLLING
THE AIRPORT, JOE, IF YOU CAN'T
CONTROL THE PERIMETER?
THE PEOPLE CONTROLLING THE
PERIMETER RIGHT NOW, THAT WOULD
BE THE TALIBAN.
AND IF PEOPLE CAN'T GET INSIDE,
HOW DO WE GET THEM HOME?
IT IS SO SAD THAT EVEN JOE'S
FRIENDS IN THE LIBERAL MEDIA
CANNOT AND WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SHIELD HIM FROM THIS CRISIS, AND
FRANKLY, FOR GOOD REASON.
WOULD YOU WANT YOUR FAMILY IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS?
FORCED TO TRY AND CLAW THEIR WAY
THROUGH SEVERAL TALIBAN
CHECKPOINTS IN THE MIDST OF THIS
UTTER CHAOS, AND DEPEND ON THE
GOODWILL OF THE TALIBAN?
A TERRORIST ORGANIZATION?
TO ALLOW YOU TO GO TO THE
AIRPORT WHEN THEY ARE BEATING
PEOPLE?
TODAY'S STATE DEPARTMENT MEMO
SAYS "WE CAN'T SECURE YOUR SAFE
PASSAGE TO THE AIRPORT AND WE
CAN'T GUARANTEE WHAT ENTRY
POINTS WILL STILL BE OPEN."
IT IS A NIGHTMARE APPEARED WITH
THE HORRORS DON'T END THERE.
THE LUCKY ONES THAT HAVE GOTTEN
PAST THE TALIBAN BEATINGS AND
THE CHECKPOINTS AND ACTUALLY
MADE IT TO THE AIRPORT, THEY ARE
THEN FORCED TO WAIT FOR HOURS ON
END, TRAPPED BETWEEN THE WALLS
OF THE AIRPORT AND THE TALIBAN
FIGHTERS THAT ARE SURROUNDING
THE PERIMETER OF THE AIRPORT
BEHIND THEM.
OTHERS ARE FORCED TO MOVE FROM
GATE TO GATE TO GATE UNTIL THEY
CAN FIND ONE THAT IS ACTUALLY
OPEN.
THE GATES OPEN AND CLOSE AT A
MOMENT'S NOTICE, AND IN BETWEEN
EACH GATE IS ANOTHER TALIBAN
CHECKPOINT.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE
TALIBAN ARE USING THESE
CHECKPOINTS, THEY ARE SEARCHING
FOR ANYONE AND EVERYONE ON THEIR
HIT LIST SPIRIT AND TO MAKE
MATTERS EVEN WORSE TONIGHT, FOR
OVER EIGHT HOURS TODAY, NOT A SK
OFF FROM THAT AIRPORT, KARZAI
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT, NOT ONE.
THE PRIMARY REASON FOR THE HOLD
UP, ONLY A HANDFUL OF COUNTRIES
ARE NOW ACTUALLY ACCEPTING OUR
FLIGHTS, INCLUDING QATAR, WHICH
THEY ARE NOW SAYING ARE AT FULL
CAPACITY.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
TAKE ANY MORE INCOMING FLIGHTS,
AND MEANWHILE, THE EVER SO
COMPASSIONATE JOE BIDEN IS
BLOCKING AFGHAN REFUGEES AND
THEIR FAMILIES FROM FLYING TO
THE UNITED STATES.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A PROMISE TO
THEM THAT IF IT EVER GOT THIS
BAD, WE WOULD GET THEM OUT.
DON'T HAVE TO STAY HERE FOREVER,
BUT WE PROMISED THEM TO GET THEM
OUT, BECAUSE THEY WILL DIE.
AND GET THIS, ACCORDING TO
JOE BIDEN, ALL OF OUR ALLIES,
EVERY ONE OF THEM, THEY ARE
APPLAUDING HIS HEROIC
LEADERSHIP.
OKAY.
ANOTHER LIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVE SEEN NO QUESTION OF
OUR CREDIBILITY FROM OUR ALLIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
I HAVE SPOKEN WITH OUR NATO
ALLIES.
WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH NATO ALLIES
AND THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR HAS
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH HIS
COUNTERPARTS THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD AND OUR ALLIES, AS HAS THE
GENERAL, EXCUSE ME, KEEP CALLING
HIM A GENERAL, BUT MY SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, I
HAVE NOT SEEN THAT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THE EXACT
OPPOSITE, I'VE GOTTEN THE EXACT
OPPOSITE, AS WE ARE ACTING,
COMMITTING TO WHAT WE SAID WE
WOULD DO.
>> Sean: HERE IS A HEADLINE
FOR YOU, JOE, FROM "THE
TELEGRAPH," "BRITISH PARLIAMENT
HOLDS JOE BIDEN IN CONTENT OVER
AFGHANISTAN."
HERE IS ANOTHER: "NATO ALLIES
RETHINK ON ALLIANCE AFTERWARD
BIDEN'S UNILATERAL AFGHANISTAN
EXIT."
ANOTHER: "LEADERS BLAST BIDEN
OVER AFGHANISTAN.
WE THOUGHT AMERICA WAS BACK."
JOE BIDEN ABANDONED OUR ALLIES
FROM OUR FRIENDS, ALL PARTNERS,
AND EVEN OUR OWN FELLOW CITIZENS
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT,
FRANKLY, BUT DON'T WORRY,
ACCORDING TO JOE, A LITTLE CHAOS
WAS BOUND TO HAPPEN, THAT WAS
ALL FACTORED INTO THIS, HE SAID,
AND THERE IS NO REASON FOR US TO
BEGIN TO BE IN THE REGION
BECAUSE AL QAEDA, HE THINKS,
MAGICALLY HAS DISAPPEARED,
PERHAPS NOBODY TOLD HIM THAT
THEY WERE RELEASED FROM PRISON'S
JUST DAYS AGO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET'S PUT THIS THING IN
PERSPECTIVE HERE.
WHAT INTEREST DO WE HAVE IN
AFGHANISTAN AT THIS POINT, WITH
AL QAEDA GONE?
WE WENT TO AFGHANISTAN FOR THE
EXPRESS PURPOSE OF GETTING RID
OF AL QAEDA IN AFGHANISTAN, AS
WELL AS, AS WELL AS GETTING
USAMA BIN LADEN.
AND WE DID.
>> Sean: AND TODAY, JOE'S OWN
PENTAGON SAID THE EXACT
OPPOSITE, THAT AL QAEDA IS VERY
MUCH ALIVE AND WELL IN
AFGHANISTAN, WORKING ALONGSIDE
THEIR TALIBAN PARTNERS, AND WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE AN EMBASSY
PRESENCE OR INTEL ASSETS LEFT TO
COUNTER ANY THREAT.
AND NOW, THE TALIBAN MAY EVEN --
AL QAEDA -- HAS ACCESS TO
MASSIVE STOCKPILES, BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF SOPHISTICATED
WEAPONRY THAT WE LEFT
BEHIND, BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
CONTINGENCY PLAN, THOUSANDS OF
GUNS IN ARMORED VEHICLES, YEP,
EVEN BLACK HAWK MILITARY,
NIGHT VISION GOGGLES, AMMO
UNIFORMS, YOU NAME IT, THEY
GOT IT ALL.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THESE TALIBAN FIGHTERS ARE NOW
MOCKING THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA IN THEIR OWN PROPAGANDA,
DRESSED UP IN GEAR TAKEN THAT WE
LEFT, THAT JOE LEFT THEM, FROM
U.S. STOCKPILES.
ONE THE NOTORIOUS GLOBAL
TERRORIST WAS EVEN PICTURED WITH
A U.S. M4 RIFLE, FLANKED BY
OTHER TERRORISTS WEARING U.S.
MILITARY GEAR FROM HEAD TO TOE.
THERE IS NO PLAN TO RECOVER OUR
GEAR OR WEAPONS, THERE IS NO
PLAN TO GET RID OF THEM OR DEST.
THERE ISN'T EVEN A PLAN TO
RESCUE OUR FELLOW AMERICAN
CITIZENS, YEP, THAT ARE HELD
BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
GET TO THE AIRPORT, SAYS BIDEN.
TRUST THE TALIBAN.
THEY GUARANTEED SAFE PASSAGE,
HE'S TELLING US.
TAKE YOUR BEATINGS, RISK YOUR
LIFE, WE CAN TO ENSURE YOUR
SAFETY?
THAT'S HIS PLAN?
THAT'S IT?
THE TALIBAN FEARED
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY REALIZED THAT THEIR ACTIONS
WOULD HAVE IMMEDIATE AND DIRE
CONSEQUENCES, AND AS A RESULT,
NO AMERICANS WERE KILLED FOR
WELL OVER A YEAR, THE LAST YEAR
OF DONALD TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY.
NOW, NO ONE RESPECTS JOE BIDEN.
NOT THE TALIBAN, NOT OUR
GEOPOLITICAL FLOWS, RUSSIA,
HOSTILE REGIME, CHINA, THE
MULLAHS IN IRAN, THEY ARE ALL WR
ALLIES DON'T EVEN TRUST US AT
THIS POINT.
AND ACCORDING TO A BREAKING NEW
REPORT FROM BLOOMBERG, BIDEN
PROMISED TO G7 LEADERS THE U.S.
WOULD KEEP A SECURITY PRESENCE
IN AFGHANISTAN KABUL SAFE, AND
THEN UTTERLY FAILED TO KEEP THAT
PROMISE.
WELL, TONIGHT, I ALWAYS SAY LET
NOT YOUR HEART BE TROUBLED, MY
HEART IS TROUBLED.
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS ARE IN DEEP
TROUBLE TONIGHT, BEHIND ENEMY
LINES, OUR FRIENDS, OUR ALLIES
ARE IN DEEP TROUBLE BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
YOU KNOW, LEAVE NO MAN OR WOMAN
BEHIND?
WELL, GREAT BRITAIN AND FRANCE,
TO THEIR CREDIT, THEY SENT IN
TROOPS TO KABUL TO ESCORT
CITIZENS FROM KABUL,
SUCCESSFULLY, TO THE AIRPORT.
WHY HAVEN'T WE?
WE HAVE THE BEST MILITARY
FIGHTING FORCE ON THE FACE OF
THE EARTH.
YEAH, AMERICANS NOW CAN'T GET TO
THE AIRPORT, HELD HOSTA